[Musique]
et oui les pommes se font des couleurs
et les feuilles se meurt il ya aussi
l'automne qui sort son mouchoir
alors là pas de doute c'est du passé que
l'on va parler
le passé n'est pas triste les feuilles
se meurt c'est vrai mais en couleur
comme une fête l'automne n'est pas une
tradition c'est l'habitude l'habitude de
la vie une habitude qui soudain gros lot
comme le ver d'amore ce qui reste de la
tradition d'automne on à l'envi de le
connaître de le saisir vite parce que
l'on sent le temps pressait glisser
entre les doigts du paysan il verse déjà
un verre près du cul de la tonne et
bientôt se souvient du cidre d'automne
ont tangué main quand le mou large
heatley j'étais enfant le cidre était
bon aujourd'hui à la presse qui crachent
dedans ils savent bien la pop eurent est
ce qu'on fait le cidre maintenant comme
on le faisait autrefois a tourné avec le
cheval
le moulard en un an vent de mon hangar
et maintenant c'est plus comme ça
annoncé la presse maintenant qui vient
et ce fait le cidre aussi mots ben il
est possible patients matin cuvées ont
été élevées
oui une nuit à godollo dedans un peu son
black death est meilleure à dahouët le
succès remontait d'ailleurs voir le
sucre maintenant dollemard comme du
sucre en poudre qui punit mois à 14
sérieusement mais je vois ça se passe
entre opposants à mais réellement entre
amis enlevez bon sens il fallait deux
copains alors on faisait le cidre
ensemble auquel cochons ensemble pareil
et embaucher le bout des ensembles
c'était une sorte de fête même
réellement et maintenant ça se passe
plus comme ça et ça se perd un peu hein
c'est plus le même la méthode
le temps est bon
quand les pommes avait vomi leur cidre
le paysan éponger sa misère comptait
quatre sous lyautey le ciel pas clair et
se disait que le froid engin devra
bientôt l'horizon c'était l'heure de
l'autre bonne tradition d'automne
jenson allait par devant le vent
qu'aucun dire aux voisins de prêter la
main au lendemain le cochon est bon a
saigné la femme l'a nourri tout l'an
passé qui nous nourrissent tous leur
avenir les cochons est enlevé dans l'est
dont le seul biais là a un coût qui
donna à g uerre gaudette chose à espérer
vous fait rire sénégal
je sais que ça ça marche oui seven égale
sénégal alors mon père que j'arrivais de
cool non d'aioun ya quatre cochons vont
dans la danse dans la soie que l'on
dispose là vous avez rarement là c'est
nous qu'on m'offre du rabot
des producteurs français à l'intérieur
on sait le plus les cochons pas ici
encore ça en place à bâle il en est mis
dans le congélateur mon fils il ya des
morceaux qui s'en vont et viennent en
cours des fermiers tiff
il préfère la mettre en scène country il
met dans le congélateur quinzaine de
grossouvre des côtes 0,6 en cours de
l'armée sur des mavs ont regardé tout le
monde seul après congélateur
j'étais aussi bon oui sur simplement
plus à cette congélation là il y avoir
c'était une sorte de petit fayt
quand on fait le cochon ah ben oui oui
moi j'ai déjà proposé leurs dirigeants
n'ont pu sans doute mes os x dans les
villes ont mangé oui mes amis on devient
il veut dire il veut dire que la nullité
puis la lapi créé le site quand il y
avait plusieurs cochon le soir de paix y
aller faire dodo à l'automne il a un
cochon de tuer par ici nationalement
vraiment naoui ses bailleurs et tout le
monde se réunissent et abat mais
sûrement pour la fête du boudin fait un
peu de charcuterie oui c'est par amour
du métier de toujours fait ça m'a fait
quelque chose on peut pas tout le temps
et à rien faire
j'espère le faisait
[Musique]
on était trois frères je fais williams a
été arrêté et du compte il veut c'est
pas un métier de fainéant j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut pas trop nos
meilleurs n'ont pas moment il ya des
jours que ça va emmerder au bal de
servir la paix avec nous
il ya plus longtemps des gens six
fermiers sont partis n'ont laissé que
deux c'est plus la fête
le cochon se meurt d'ennui les hommes
aussi la femme apporte en garde et les
gestes des vieux la saucisse et le pâté
n'ont pas bien changé le cochon est mort
mais sans tradition l'homme marche son
bonhomme de chemin
écrasant ses traditions bousculant ses
bons sentiments crèvera comme le cochon
et le mord tremblera comme une horloge
et tout recommence les pommes se font
des couleurs les feuilles se meurt et y
à l'automne qui sort son mouchoir et la
vie qui est salie et la vie qui grelotte
à perdre ses habitudes
[Musique]